hello my name is nila nila the circus
I'm a sister professor at Universidade
de Sao Paulo Brazil and I'll present our
experience about using Mathematica
dynamic analysis to provide the students
of visual understanding about electrical
concepts and electrical drives for
students there are electrical and non
electrical engineering students
hello everybody I apologize for my poor
English it's my first time here in the
conference so I hope that the message is
clear my name is Milan I'm assistant
professor for for at Universidad de Sao
Paulo in Brazil and we are presenting
here our experience in using dynamic
efficient allative for of Mathematica to
provide the students a visual
understanding because we are responsible
me and my colleagues in our department
can you hear me
I don't know all responsible for courses
that that about a basic electricity that
are offered to students they are
electrical and non electrical
engineering students
well my the Politecnico school is part
of the universe studied some paulo in
brazil it's older than the Goosby
Politecnico school was created in 1893
and now it has 100 within 25 years and
you speak is the one of the is the the
most important university in brazil it
it was created in 1934 we have almost
5000 students enrolled for 17 by
engineering courses in my department in
poly technical school is responsible for
some of these areas in electrical
engineering about automation power
electronics fundamentals of power
systems in disciplines about energy and
basic electricity here are offered to
most of these 17 courses in intervals a
lot of professors like me well I am I'm
using mathematical for mathematical for
only 3 years so
I apologize because the my my code is
not as clean so maybe it was effective
this photo is not mine I use it from
Wikipedia but it it is here to show that
we have a few hours to show students
there are from production engineering
and chemical engineering how this works
how electric motors works so we use it
Mathematica for that it's one of the
topics that we trying to teach in so the
first one to the the first topic we
covered in about motors is how it can be
it can spin so we had we have we had
three three hours for for the students
to learn how it works and to manage to
start a real motor deity they are
presented to a three-phase motor
electric motor and they need to make it
through it rotate without the wrong if
with the the right connections in for a
three-phase so first of all we try to
use to use manipulate and get the images
from this manipulate throughout your
presentation so the code is here but
it's not it's not so clean because I'm
not real programmer I'm not a
computation engineering so maybe if I my
code it's not so so neat but I could
manage to do that so
instead of using a board in the chalk we
prefer to make it run so this in this
picture we have a coil in which a
current is present in magnetic field
could be in black so the interaction
between the current and the magnetic
field generates two forces that makes
the do this the coil true true spin and
all this those images these images are
created using manipulate in Mathematica
so we can collect all this to a
presentation that is not made with
Mathematica because I'm alone in my
department using it instead I hope I
could spread the news but we use latech
to build presentations so you can easily
connect maybe 34 maybe 35 36 images of
them and so we can use a user feature
for latech that it's animate so we can
use it to create a PDF that students can
play forward and in the rivers so they
can believe that this can happen and
then with a for DC machine when it
almost gets it a clear view point a
commuter that is draw a draw here in
gray it was kind of difficult to make
this in using 3d because it's difficult
to draw a part of a cylinder using this
dysfunction right I managed to make it
and then after the deck liberal point
inertia keeps it running and so the
commuters makes the coil touch the
source in the opposite polarity so
current is reversed so
Carrillo continues to rotate then we
have similar to a seeker AC machines
alternate current machines so the field
in this way that field it's not a
constant it's it managed to to rotate so
forces are rotating to so the machine
keeps running one one question students
made is how this field is rotating so I
prepare some manipulate based on draw is
that our colleagues they draw the date
April maybe five or six drawing by hand
so I managed to up to automate this so
students this they told me that now they
believe that the the the magnetic field
in the center of the machine is running
because here we are we have three cords
the three three-phase current one in red
one in blue 120 degrees delayed and
another one in green this current are
put in this in this and it is motor in
view from the front side so a current
come gets inside the screen in this
position and no out inside of the screen
this position in outside no no outside
from the position in inside from that
position so they generate three magnetic
fields in red blue and green in the
resulting field it's the this gray so
when the time runs the current here
changes and so they
magnetic field here but the Sun is
contest contest constant with different
angle so we save a lot of minutes
drawings in the in the board showing
this scene so the students you can see
this in Rome before and after the
classes and students are very excited
about how easy is to do these coats and
Muslim of then asks me so I show the
code and if they want to improve it it's
free for them and so this is the result
from their late from the latest so I
only put it in wrapping in latech this
these bottles here are native from
Bheema package animate from Bheema
package 1f another concept that we use
it to to make manipulate to is one a
very frequent question is about why do
we need to correct power factor for
alternate current circuits when we use
circuits that are not exactly modeling
as a resistive one when you have some
part of inductive and capacitive
elements they are kind of displacement
between current and voltage curves as we
are interested in not not in voltage
incur or current you are interested in
power a power that makes them the world
run so we are interested in the product
in in instantaneous product of these
curves that the voltage and the current
in if they are dis displaced
the product it's not a only positive
there are parts that are negative so it
it it is kind of a less Fe efficient
because some sometimes you give power
sometimes you get power so they don't
need the IDO into your word we have this
kind of curve this kind of curves with
about voltage and current in phase so
how we could correct the secret to to
get the right how can I screw this okay
to get it we have to some if we had a
current that it's lagging from the the
current that is lagging from the voltage
the peak is a occurs after the peak of
voltage if we some a some current that
is leading the peak occurs before the
peak of the voltage we can get a curve
that it's less displayed less displaced
so to calculate what is the exact curve
that exact courage that we must sum or
the exact capacitive capacitor that we
have to that you need to add we need to
show students that you have the best way
is to represent a single sinusoidal
curves with phasers that must that can
be shown in this animation that we done
with manipulate with with Mathematica
true with me if we see the balls in the
right side of this plot stop
the balls in the right side of this plot
it goes together with the deployed a the
other plot with time so we can represent
all the Scopes in solution sinusoidal
curves with vectors that are rotating
and we forget the point where the time
is zero or a multiple of periods we can
use this vectors that we call phasers to
do our our calculations you can sum
these phasers and the sum is equivalent
to sum those two currents is the first
step that students should be able to
correctly calculate the capacitors and
then
and then we they are able to choose to
to see what happens when we in when we
add the correct capacitor to the secret
here we have we had a motor motor here
there is a part resistive and part
inductive and so the current that this
voltage here needs to supply its 82
compares if we add a collar a capacitor
to the secret some of the current is
provided by this capacitor and then
they're sourcing the source only has to
provide 77 and pairs of current so the
secret gets more efficient and the
student can shot you can see what
happens when we add more in more
capacitor and then the points where we
had too much capacitor so the current
begins to to increase again so this is a
true added to our light latekka
presentation so students can experiment
each at 8:00 at home in even they can
see if the the calculations are correct
well my the story of my experience using
Mathematica begins in 2015
three years ago so I started to use it
by myself I wasn't very interested about
the visual results and dynamic features
of mathematical about manipulate so I
went to a Brasilia conference here I
don't know it in its line I went to a
Brazilian conferences it's always
started to change experience about it I
read the book from Stephen Wolfram and I
use it
a very known internet forum so it helped
me to to to do a poor recording but it
that it works the lecturer that the next
one it's a challenge for me because I am
a lab professor so this is our lab kit
that students use students from chemical
engineering Production Engineering
so these are some relays um some relays
that I use it to to here we connect some
resistors or motors so students need to
do the correct connections so when they
press this button for example motor has
to be started and keep running and then
then when they press the the Daath
bottle they have to stop the motor and
for example they have to after 10
seconds the motor is running another
motor has to be started too so how they
could do it do this using this kit so I
I wondered if it's possible to do it to
do it using Mathematica how students
could simulate it at home or to do the
or study for the for the exam for
example so I managed to do it it's quite
off slow but I don't know any other any
other programming language that I could
use to do that so in this in this screen
it is an edit screen I'm sorry it's in
Portuguese now I could not translate it
to English so here students can make its
project so we have a button here on
button and off button a fuse to protect
the secret and here is the coil and the
coil here c1 has three contacts here and
if they are closed a load is turned on
student can change some of the position
I'm afraid of doing that because of the
touchpad I don't have the right
procedure but it can for example delete
this context to see it if it works or
not this is I get here some for
predefined secrets then you can use it
and if you have to you can you can
create a new secret sure and then when I
go to operation screen this secret now
may be operated and this calculation is
done with graphic structures so I use it
the graph functions and I change it load
about I care about its appearance so the
labels are changed for these drawings so
the drawing is not so good and the
colors here are calculated using
highlight function flow graph functions
so I can I die it I did it maybe one
year ago but there's something about
calculating the path and highlighted the
path if it's okay
it this coil will be turned on so I
press the the on button and then it
works and when I wanted to stop the
motor
I used this bottle the day off bottom if
I use another secret it takes much
longer to work this this is okay it's a
more complicated circuit because I had
two coils in that timer at time is coil
you get some time here you can change
the time and then you may operate it it
takes a little bit longer
and then I can operate the system and
then it starts counting the time when it
gets ten so this contact will be closed
and the second load will be turned on so
I can turn it off well this this the
following notebooks was made in with my
undergrad students the first I will show
you is made with marina Polly Lu that
graduated two years ago and then she's
wanted to do some manipulate things
about power systems when we this is for
specific specifically for electrical
engineering students because we we deal
with 3 phase circuits that are
unbalancing when we get when we when
when the three-phase are balancing we
have this kind of thing three currents
are have the same magnitude and they
they are the phases difference is 120
degrees but when they are not balancing
we have a different different amplitudes
or different phase angles so the first
the first steps to understand this kind
of circuits it's sure separate it as a
sum of three a well behaved sister
circles one with with this difference
another with the same differences with
two phases switch and one with three
voltages or currents it exactly equal so
we use a locator in some material
operations to
show how this could work so instead of
using calculators you can see how it
works now that you works from the
another work for marina if I'm sorry I
don't know what's happening here but let
me see if it works
as the okay it works as of this of all
of these notebooks were made in
different times with different very
verbose but from different persons maybe
they have problems to run it together in
the same notebook so in this notebook we
show how to calculate and short secrets
for three-phase secrets and with
different kind of Transformers for
example if we had grounding in one of
these transformers current may flow
through ground so if you have a ground
circuit a short secret there will be
current
if there is no grounding so part of the
secret it's open so part of the current
will not exist so we can choose here if
we get or not grounding in this case for
example this case is okay but we have if
we have short secret in this point here
the curve it has no it has no path to
track this so the current here in this
table in this table here is zero but if
I put grounding in this in this path so
current can exist and it stated here in
this table and I have I have a few
seconds but I want to show two works for
my two students one of them is Fernando
and he tried to he managed to do
notebook talking about a wind generator
and generator and turbines but he wanted
to to do it without using manipulate
because he wanted to trick you to
explore my Mathematica and to see if
it's possible to switch between
different screens only clicking on then
so they made this day he managed to do
that so here we had a a curve of torque
in in the in that generator so if you
wanted to to see the curve for power in
more detail only you have to click here
and so the current the curve is shown
with more zoom and also for this for the
screen show so we have to explore it it
was a great job that Fernando did and
another one the last one is my time is
over
is it was the last budget was the first
Judit that work with money play with
Mathematica with me we did it together
with another professor professor Silvio
and the students was Vinicius it's quite
heavy we have here a manipulate with 8
steps that talks about how we can select
and lack electrical motors based on some
desired features for example what kind
of load we have to move if we had a a
load with more torque we have here so
this motor it's not suitable because in
the beginning of rotation the torque is
not enough to move the load so if we use
a different starchy method for example
this kind here
we are not able in not a yet to push it
but maybe we could do it with a slower
with a slower load so students or any
user can switch can choose different
pyramids of the motor using this in
notebook that Venus is created thank you
all for coming
if you have any questions I'm sorry I am
a little bit late
[Applause]